foreign
[Music]
welcome to Shutter Island you're hereby
required to surrender your Firearms we
are duly appointed Federal Marshals but
during your stay you will obey protocol
is that understood
we take only the most dangerous damaged
patients once no other Hospital can
manage
from a violent Defenders right
they've hurt people murdered them in
some cases in almost all cases yes we
try to provide them with the measure of
calm
personally doctor I'd have to say screw
their sense of calm
so this prison Escapes in the last 24
hours we don't know how she got out of
her room this is if she evaporated
straight through the walls
we haven't heard the truth once yet but
no one will talk it's like this
this
it's all down all the lines even radio
whatever the hell is going on here it's
bad
ask you some questions okay
do you know what fear does to the mind
corrodes it rust sip
this is a game
roaring somewhere
I've built something valuable here I'm
not going to give up without a fight
what if what you were looking into them
they were looking into you now they have
a spot yeah now let me see your face let
me see your damn face now
oh
wouldn't you agree when you see a
monster you must stop it
[Music]
you like what you do for a living
these things you see
you have to wear blinders sometimes most
times
foreign
detective William Somerset is looking
for a way out you're retiring six more
days and you're all the way gone so how
long have you lived here too long
detective David Mills is looking for a
way in we'll be spending every waking
hour together from now until the time I
leave I'll show you who your friends and
enemies are look I will come here
homicide they're caught in a game no
fingerprints and no Witnesses of any
kind nope not the only thing we know
about that guy right now is he's totally
insane with a price of sin
gluttony you're going to come take a
look at this greed no one touches
anything sloth wrath Pride lust and envy
seven you can expect five more of these
body was found on Tuesday morning I hate
this city
[Applause]
this will be the very definition of
Swift Justice
there are two more bodies two more
victims the sky is methodical exacting
worst of all patient
laughing at us
he had a gun
he's two meters away from completing his
masterpiece
[Music]
let's finish it Brad Pitt Morgan Freeman
Gwyneth Paltrow
[Music]
like this
no
seven
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Nick Dunn you're probably the most hated
man in America right now
killing your wife Nick
everyone told us and told us marriage is
hard work
work not for me and Nick as you all know
my wife Amy Elliott Dunn disappeared
three days ago I had nothing to do with
The Disappearance of my wife I have
nothing to hide Sammy got friends we can
talk to no not really you don't know if
she has friends you don't know what she
does all day and you don't know your
wife's blood type
[Music]
is being nice to the people who are
volunteering to help find Amy I will
practice believing my husband
love me wrong
seen that guy in the glasses before
Amy's the kind of girl who attracts
admirers whoever took her's bound to
bring her back I'm hoping you can tell
me what this means I'm gonna solve Amy's
treasure hunt seeing this girl around
here yeah I remember her I know you I
saw you at the volunteer Center I wanted
to help what you want she wanted a gun
we are all scared but we are all here
now I feel like something to be
jettisoned if necessary
I feel like I could disappear the
Hallmark of a sociopath is a lack of
empathy Amy lost a lot of blood in there
then somebody mopped it up why'd they
mop up the blood if they're trying to
Stage a crime scene whatever they found
I think it's safe to assume that it's
very bad I finally realized I am
frightened of my own husband I would
show you as if you do in a deposition
what to say what not to say a trained
monkey a trained monkey who doesn't get
Lethal Injections she's going to eat you
alive you assaulted her it's not good
enough for you I hit her it's not even
cold
absolutely not I never touched her being
out with Nick is involved in The
Disappearance of our daughter without a
body without a murder weapon their only
hope is a confession you need to tell me
how was your marriage are you asking me
if I killed my wife none of my dreams
this man of my
money what about my son this man May
kill me in her own worms this man me
truly
kill me
you ever hear the expression simplest
answer is often the correct one actually
I've never found that to be true
there's one thing you should know about
me
I specialize in a very specific type of
security
subconscious security
you're talking about dreams
[Music]
Mr Cole has a job offer he would like to
discuss with you we've got a work
placement
not exactly
we create the world of the dream
we bring the subject into that dream
and they fill it with their secrets
then you break in and steal it well it's
not strictly speaking leader
it's called Inception already
[Music]
I think
I found and this last job that's how I
get there
[Music]
dreams feel real while we're in them
it's only when we wake up that we
realize something was actually strange
[Music]
dreams classic
I have it under control
[Music]
I hate to see out of control
we mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
[Music]
foreign
car
[Music]
what are we doing here
what the hell is going on
I was sent to get you for a reason
there's a flower on the pillows a flower
in the bathroom like we're important the
only chance we have is if all three of
us go crazy on this guy who is that she
can help us
[Applause]
don't worry
he's not allowed to touch you
he knows what you're here for
lessons to me
my name's Hedwig how old are you nice
I've never seen a case like this before
23 identities live in Kevin's body
who are you
help me get out of here Hedwig are you
trying to trick me I'm telling you
multiple personalities can change their
body chemistry with their thoughts
someone's coming for you
[Music]
the Beast
there's a man here he abducted us and
he's going to kill me
or meant for something something
horrible
laughs the world will understand now
[Music]
the Beast is real
he's done awful things to people and
he'll do awful things to you
[Music]
come in close because the more you think
you see
thank you
it'll be to fool you
ladies and gentlemen grab final tricks
we are going to rob a bank
on the count of three you will be
teleported through space and time to
your bank in Paris one two three
everyone in this room was a victim of
Hard Times some of you lost your homes
your car and so tonight we're gonna
return some of that money back to you
can you explain to me how you went from
Las Vegas to Paris in three seconds what
did the kids call it these days oh Magic
first rule of magic always be the
smartest guy in the room
your bank was the distraction
wow they set up the real trick
expose them now and Destroy them
hang on hang on
I've got nothing okay thank you thank
you for the delay
whatever this Grand trick is it was
designed long time ago
and I believe that what's about to
follow
is really going to amaze
[Music]
oh
look closely because the closer you
think you are the less you'll actually
see
there are days that Define your story
beyond your life
the day they arrived
I'm coming with GT weapons from
intelligence pack your bags
at the top of everyone's list when it
comes to translations
I already won what do they want where
are they from you'll be reporting to me
but you'll be working with him when
you're in the show that's what they call
him the UFO
[Music]
carted off in the Medevac
not everyone is wired for what you're
about to do it's what they look like
you'll see soon enough
every 18 hours a doll opens up that's
where we go in
[Music]
yeah that has happened
thank you
[Music]
they arrive
you need to see me
[Music]
now that's a proper introduction
more objects have landed around the
world this is one of 12. I'm never going
to be able to speak their words got two
days figure something out
I am human
it's their language
you need to make sure that they
understand the difference between a
weapon and a tool language is messy and
sometimes one can be both
dreaming and their language
they prodding us to fight sales this is
just a way to force us to work together
for once it's more complicated how is it
more complicated Russia just executed
one of their own to keep their secrets
got 21 hours before they start global
war so how do we clarify their
intentions I go back in
yeah
well is this feel worse
[Music]
foreign
thing that matters is the ending
it's the most important part of the
story
and this one is very good this one is
perfect
for more rainy
every story is a window into another
world
but some windows
should never be opened
all right
you stole my story
I don't believe I know you I know you Mr
Rainey that's what matters you stole my
story
[Music]
kind of an amazing coincidence
Stories being so much alike her death
would be a mystery taught down he's dead
the guy calls himself shooter maybe my
name not shooter
hello
remember my story Secret Window
you and me the only people that know
about that right
you scared too easy
you're up there alone Anything could
happen and nobody would know
my ending
I want you to fix it
[Music]
I don't think shoot is just some nut I'd
like to know what I'm dealing with here
you don't want to know
I will burn your life and every person
in it like a cane field in a high wind
the only thing that matters is the
ending
the most important part of the story the
you got your toothbrush do you have your
deodorant do you have your cozy clothes
got it
do they know I'm black should they you
might wanna you know Mom and Dad my
black boyfriend will be coming up this
weekend I just don't want you to be
shocked but he's a black man if I never
seen you like this before bruh big
families taking road trips don't come
back all bougie man come back get your
damn pants up to your damn stomach
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
yeah we're just heading up for the
weekend can I see your license please he
wasn't driving I didn't ask who was
driving I asked to see his ID
call me Dean and you're hungry my man so
how long has this been going on Miss
this thing
hired Georgina and Walter to help care
for my parents when they died I couldn't
bear to let them go
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna quit she'd take care of that
for you how hypnosis
I'm good actually
are you ready for this I'm back in the
beat so look I go do my research
apparently a whole bunch of Brothers
been missing in this suburb but it's
cool bro you're not scared of this man
because you see no brother around here
Chris was just telling me how he felt
much more comfortable with my being here
get out sorry man get out yo
Bros we gotta go is everything okay
roast the keys just get a kiss I don't
know where they are rose
[Music]
wait wait wait wait
if there's too many white people I get
nervous
oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
come on come on terrible thing to waste
[Music]
shoot me
come on no I can't do it
how'd you like that how do you do it
magic
I'll perform this feat in a manner never
before seen by yourselves or any other
audience anywhere in the world
this trip is top-notch you need to
celebrate
[Applause]
a real magician tries to invent
something new
something that other magicians will
scratch their heads over I suppose you
have such a treat
someone they're gonna remember me for
what happened
to the greatest magic trick I've ever
seen
I need to know how he does it he has no
trick it's real
every great magic trick consists of
three acts the first deck is called The
Pledge the magician shows you something
ordinary but of course it probably isn't
the second act is called the turn he's
obsessed with discovering your method
the magician makes us ordinary something
do something extraordinary huh now
you're looking for the secret
but you won't find it
that's why there's a third act called
The Prestige
this in part with the twists and turns
where lives hang into balance
and you see something shocking you've
never seen before
this was built by a man who can actually
do what magicians pretend to do real
magic I know what you really are how
does he do it you want the truth nothing
is impossible
no more secrets secrets in my life
[Music]
I want you to hit me as hard as you can
why how much can you know by yourself
you've never been a fight wait let me
start earlier
like many of you I was stuck you want me
to de-prioritize my current reports yeah
until you buy some status upgrades make
these your primary action items I
couldn't sleep no you can't die from
insomnia I'd flip through catalogs and
wonder what kind of dining set defines
me as a person this is your life and
it's ending one minute at a time
I prayed for a different life so
this is how I met Tyler Durden come on
hit me before I lose my nerd
okay
in the ear
it was on the tip of everyone's tongue
can I be next we just gave it a name
gentlemen welcome to Fight Club first
rule of Fight Club is
[Music]
nice you do not talk about Fight Club is
that your blood
yeah
club we all started seeing things
differently we're gonna have to keep me
up all night and she ruined everything
you're not into right no God not at all
all been raised on television to believe
that one day we'd all be millionaires
and movie gods and rock stars but we
won't he had a plan
to what purpose in Tyler we trusted I
gotta take a Fight Club up a notch each
one of you has a homework assignment
you're gonna start a fight with a total
stranger
that's not necessary
[Music]
you were looking for a way to change
your life
[Music]
I'm stopping this it's already done shut
up
what game are you playing oh my God
[Music]
this is too much in the end you will
thank me wow wow
did you fight anyone who would you fight
Shatner I'd buy William Shatner
[Music]
remember when we were kids and I used to
have those blackouts
some of those memories been coming back
to me there are moments in life we
choose to remember do you think that
we'll be together forever
[Music]
can never forget
all I know is that by reading these
journals I might be able to get Kaylee
back I'd think twice about what you're
doing you could wake up a lot more
messed up than you are now
yourself like this before but what if
you could go back in time you are
completely relaxed think of it like a
movie you can pause
rewind
or slow down could you save the one
person that mattered the most
honey are you all right
incredible
I lost you once and I'm not losing you
again I mean you never lost me what are
you talking about you got nice life you
stay away from us
it's been a while since I'll come what
about Kaylee is she all right
if I go back to the beginning I might be
able to save her just tell me if you see
anything weird weirder than this
[Music]
you were happy once
with me
why don't you go back man save me how
are you doing this you wouldn't believe
me if I told you
you can't change who people are without
destroying who they were
every time I try to go back in time and
help someone everything just goes wrong
Butterfly Effect
[Music]
London College of fashion
room is on the top floor it's perfect I
love it
I can live any place in any time I'd
live here in London
in the 60s
last night I saw something in my dreams
[Music]
there was a girl
and you are Sandy
[Music]
thank you I got this kind of gift
I can see people faces things are
discarded this is the closest most
people ever get to their dreams
[Music]
yeah I don't want to do this do you
think you can just walk away it really
happened
did you see
do you believe in ghosts
you witnessed the murder last night but
you believe this was a vision from the
past
the guy that killed her is to like that
I have to stop him
I know what you did I've done a lot of
things you can have to be more
specifically
[Music]
as the attorney representing Adrian's
Trust
I'm required to read a prepared
statement
Cecilia Although our relationship was
far from perfect I thought that you
would talk to me rather than run away
are you okay
what happened to him he cut his wrist
per his final wishes you're getting five
million dollars contingent of course on
the fine print it
foreign
[Music]
wouldn't kill himself
listen you're getting your freedom back
okay
don't let him haunt you
hello
[Music]
I'm scared don't have to be scared
anymore he was a sociopath completely in
control of everything he said that
wherever I went he would find me walk
right up to me and I wouldn't be able to
see him
are you okay someone sitting in that
chair
I found something that could prove what
I'm experiencing you need help Adrian is
dead
I went to his house today he's not dead
I have a pile of ashes in the box that
would disagree with you he has figured
out a way to be invisible the only thing
more brilliant than inventing something
that makes you invisible is coming up
with the perfect weather towards you
even in death
Adrian's true genius was how he got in
people's heads don't come any closer hey
I'm not crazy
please listen to me you're saying the
person trying to kill you
is in the room right now but we can't
see him
he's listening where are you where are
you show yourself come on do it there
you are
thank you
I guess I've already told you about my
condition 20 every time I see you you
don't remember where you've been or what
you've just done I can't make new
memories everything just fades
my wife that's sweet dying
you really want to get this guy don't
you my wife deserves vengeance
[Applause]
Somebody's gotta pay Lenny somebody
Always Pays
you have to be very careful
you wander around playing detective
maybe you should start investigating
yourself
this guy is so Disney's gonna kill me
who is he
I want my life back I think someone's
trying to kill the wrong guy you can
question everything you can never know
anything for sure there are things we
know for sure you can't trust him even
if you get revenge you're not gonna
remember it you're not even gonna know
that it happened who did this to you you
did
you don't know who you are
comments are still hidden
what else is on yeah let's see what else
is coming to you now from the largest
Studio ever constructed it's the
trumanjao
good morning oh and in case I don't see
you good afternoon good evening and good
night
no scripts no cue cards morning Spencer
how's it going what if you were watched
every moment of your life how many
cameras you got there in that town
I believe Truman is the first child to
have been legally adopted by a
corporation that's correct brilliant
what if everyone you knew was pretending
hi honey look what I got you could check
out dishwasher safe
that's amazing what if your world was
make-believe cue the sign while the
world he inhabits is counterfeit
I look
on your type there's nothing fake about
Truman himself what if you didn't know
it
until now
a lot of strange things have been
happening stand by ring cam is he
looking at us do you think he knows I
think I'm mixed up in something
something big
we accept the reality with which we're
presented
[Music]
because the last thing that I would ever
do
is lie to you Fade up music that's our
hero shot
give me some lightning
cut transmission I like your pen I was
wondering that myself Jim Carrey
The Truman Show Watch What Happens
[Music]
oh
the body of Dr Florence Weaver was found
brutally murdered in her home this
morning did you know her so but I saw
her die
I'm seeing that
I'm seeing yours as they're happening
hello
he says his name is Gabriel
someone for my past
whatever happened to you before you
joined our family hurt you in a way that
I can't even imagine
not saying that
Mandy who you talking to
is he your imaginary imaginary imagine
he's the devil
[Music]
whatever it was
bad
he killed again he's getting closer
he wants to talk to you
all right
mom what do you know
it's coming from me
who are you
okay
[Music]
hello Dr Gordon
I want to play a game your aim is to
kill Adam you have until six on the
clock to do it
the newspaper started calling him the
jigsaw Killer looks like our friend
jigsaw likes to book himself front row
seats to his own sick little games
you could be the one who put me in this
room
I'm gonna have to work together if we
want to get out of here
what is it sweetie there's a man in my
room
most people are so ungrateful to be
alive
[Music]
to overcome something you have to
understand what a perfect engine it is
he doesn't want us to cut through our
chains he wants us to cut through our
feet
thick bastard
yes I'm sick officer
there's a way out of here
we're out of time
[Music]